[Rires]
de déguster à l'aveuglette quelques-uns
de ses mails et vous allez voir que même
si on a bien rigolé c'est du sérieux
nous avons recensé à l'épicerie 8
produits surgelés c'est en crème en
conserve et 16 conserve de maïs agréés
alors je sais pas si déjà visuellement
vous voyez des bonnes différences ben
moi je la vois toi aussi la couleur
l'opacité ici il y a pas de brillance
nous avons sélectionné trois maïs agréés
entiers du plus ou moins cher et le plus
salé du lot
[Musique]
O
que je pensais le goûts la texture est
juteuse
serait le fun absolument notez que le
maïs biologique avril est le seul qui ne
provient pas du Canada
et si vous achetez au Québec mais il y a
des fortes chances que ce soit au Québec
Christian Malenfant et vice-président
mis en marché pour nordera le délai
entre la cueillette et la préparation
est super importante c'est comme ça
qu'on peut préserver la qualité de nos
produits et aussi des frais de
logistique de transport sont très élevés
ce qui fait que par défaut on veut être
près de nos marchés
à que se transforme la quasi-totalité de
la production de maïs sucré au Québec et
en Ontario peu importe la marque
notre entreprise on se plaît souvent
dire que le légume qui est le plus
proche du légume frais c'est bien le
maïs c'est réglementé par l'Agence
Canadienne d'expression des aliments
alors on a des experts qui vont regarder
cette qualité là et les appareils vont
mesurer la tendreté on regarde la
couleur la forme du grain la grosseur
puisque l'on trouve dans les conserves
et des catégories fantaisies
c'est celui qui est supérieur standard
méridienne et le choix plus bas de gamme
maintenant il y a aussi des variétés ou
des saveurs on peut dire il y a du maïs
régulier il y a du maïs super sucré dans
la tolère à ceux qui étaient plus élevés
la saveur sucrée prononcée alors comment
expliquer que maïs de même catégorie
soit si différent d'une conserve à
l'autre
en fournit selon ce quelqu'un on peut
adapter la recette un peu en taux de sel
en taux de sucre dépendamment de la
préférence des consommateurs pour cette
marque là mais on va ajuster la recette
pour plaire aux consommateurs
une quinzaine de variétés de maïs
sucrées il est difficile de faire la
distinction entre le sucre naturel et le
sucre ajouté par contre ce que l'on sait
c'est que le maïs agréé entier contient
moins de sucre ajouté par portion que le
maïs en crème
pour le maïs en crème trois produits ont
retenu notre attention j'ai envers PC
menu bleu et compliment
[Musique]
[Rires]
parce que là
en conserve la teneur en sodium varie
beaucoup de zéro à 325 mg par portion
il y a quelques années on aurait réduit
les taux de sel puis on a aussi commencé
à offrir des produits sans sel mais
c'est très populaire ça gagne en
popularité auprès des consommateurs
et finalement les maïs surgelés mais ça
vous inspire ou pas mais surgelé plus
qu'en conserve moins autant m'inspire
parce que je médite au moins c'est
naturel moi j'ai l'odeur du maïs que
j'avais pas tout à l'heure en concert
ça nous donne la différence
j'ai pas besoin
dans l'industrie on fait des choix c'est
pas le hasard qui décide que le grain de
Metz qui se retrouve dans le sac
on cueille des produits de la nature
tout à fait frais qu'on lave qu'on coupe
en surgelé on les cuit pas on fait que
les Blanchers ont les surgelés
immédiatement à très basse température
très rapidement pour justement préserver
toute la saveur
nutritionnelle des produits les ventes
de surgelés sont en croissance depuis
quelques années pas plus cher qu'en
conserve il ne contiennent ni sucre ni
celle ajoutée un petit peu plus de goût
mais je comprends pas pourquoi congeler
hyper tout son goût
c'est donc moins goûteux que quand c'est
en conserve oui oui absolument
c'est un concert le tu es un peu en
saumure
dans une boîte sans avoir de l'eau
autour ou de la saumure donc une saveur
que tu peux insérer
la version la plus économique qu'on a
trouvé en congélateur le great value et
le plus cher
mais c'est une forme c'est tout ce bel
expérience je pensais pas que il y avait
des qualités puis des sortes et puis des
goûts autant différents
[Rires]
merci beaucoup
[Musique]